In the northeast Atlantic Ocean, plankton
populations aren’t looking like they used to.
These tiny marine organisms have included
an array of diatoms and dinoflagellates and
copepods, riding the currents to food and
survival.
But as ocean waters have gotten warmer, the
populations of copepods and krill have declined
in the summer.
And at the center of it all are tiny, photosynthetic
bacteria called picocyanobacteria who may
just outlast us all.
Cyanobacteria come in many different shapes
and sizes.
Some are simple, some are long, and some are
just odd to look at.
And if we needed just one word to define
picocyanobacteria, we would probably go with
“small.”
They’re generally 0.2 to around 2 micrometers
in length, which makes them small even by
bacterial standards.
Piled together like this, they look like those
optical illusion paintings you’re supposed
to squint at to find the hidden image.
But don’t waste your time pushing your face
closer and closer to the screen.
There is no picture hiding amongst these
bacteria….
Well, or is there?
There are two genera of picocyanobacteria:
Synechococcus and Prochlorococcus.
And together, they kind of rule the world.
At the very least, they are considered to
be the most abundant photosynthetic organisms
on our planet.
The abundance of picocyanobacteria is matched
by just how geographically widespread they are.
That's made them fascinating for scientists
who want to understand how they managed
to spread so far and how their prevalence
has shaped our planet.
Assembling the history of picocyanobacteria
is a complex undertaking, but it has
some delightful theories.
Like recently, scientists came up with one
potential explanation for how picocyanobacteria
were able to spread to new parts of the ocean
hundreds or millions of years ago.
I'm going to bet that you can’t guess
how that happened…
unless you watched the video our sister
channel Eons did on this topic recently.
Here’s what you need to know first.
For a long time, picocyanobacteria were thought
to be autotrophic, meaning they could only
get their food by making it—
in their case, through photosynthesis.
But it turns out, they’re mixotrophs,
able to take in elements like carbon through
other sources—
including, it seems, a material found in arthropod
exoskeletons called chitin.
And scientists looking at the evolution of
picocyanobacteria came to an interesting conclusion:
that the picocyanobacteria might not just
have been eating chitin from ancient bug-like creatures.
They might have actually been setting sail
on them, cruising around on an edible boat
made of discarded body parts as they began
their slow but immense takeover of the ocean…
an expansion that would see them become responsible
today for around 25% of all photosynthesis
in the ocean.
This chitin raft hypothesis provides one possible
story for how picocyanobacteria spread around
the world.
But prochlorococcus and synechococcus did not
accomplish what they have accomplished just
by spreading.
They also had to adapt.
At any given point in time, their survival
is linked to a myriad of factors:
the availability of nutrients, the amount
of light they’re getting, the temperature
of the water, and the fact that every organism
around them is also attempting to survive
the same conditions.
Adaptation isn’t a challenge unique to picocyanobacteria
after all.
But they are very, very good at it.
They’re so good that it’s difficult to
summarize their abilities because they have
adapted to so many different conditions in
so many different ways.
So let’s just focus on one example.
Synechococcus are found in warm and cold waters
alike, which is challenging for organisms
like picocyanobacteria because photosynthesis
is a very temperature-sensitive process.
And yet synechococcus have managed to be found
in waters as cold as 2°C by altering the
behavior of their phycobilisome, a protein
complex that acts like an antenna to harvest
the sunlight.
Part of the job of the phycobilisome is to
regulate the amount of light that the cell receives.
It makes sure that the cell gets enough for
photosynthesis, but not so much that the organism
will accumulate a dangerous amount of reactive
oxygen species as byproducts.
One of the way that organisms like synechococcus
limit the amount of light transmitted by the
phycobilisome is through a molecule called
orange carotenoid pigment, which turns excess
light into heat.
The orange carotenoid protein isn’t limited
to picocyanobacteria.
And in fact, not all synechococcus species
produce it.
Many of the warmer-weather species don’t
even have the gene for it.
But for those species living in colder waters,
the protein is part of their survival, allowing
them to adapt to a niche that would otherwise
be unwelcoming.
So we saw one way that picocyanobacteria have
spread, and one way that they have adapted.
But that isn't insufficient to describe
their history.
Because not only do they travel and adjust.
They also compete, putting their adaptations
to use quickly when conditions change around
them with consequences for the species that
share their home.
Synechococcus can rapidly allocate resources
towards photosynthesis as waters warm, allowing
them to potentially outcompete other organisms.
So as climate change continues to see the
warming of oceans, perhaps picocyanobacteria
will continue their dominance.
In fact, we’re seeing it already—
in the krill and copepod populations that
have declined over the years in the northeast
Atlantic Ocean, where rising temperatures have been
affecting the ecosystems in a number of ways…
including through picocyanobacteria.
Because along with their talent for harvesting
light, one of other advantages that picocyanobacteria
is their small size.
It makes them able to bring in so many more
nutrients relative to their tiny bodies compared
to other plankton.
And in turn that helps them reproduce and
survive, especially as temperatures change
and affect those nutrient levels.
That’s great news for picocyanobacteria,
and terrible news for copepods.
Because those other plankton—
the larger ones that struggle to get as many
nutrients—
those are what the copepods like to eat, not picocyanobacteria,
which are just too small and lacking in nutrients.
So as the population of non-picocyanobacteria
plankton goes down, so too does the population
of copepods and krill.
And this in turn affects us in a lot of ways,
through the basic biogeochemical cycles that
serve as the foundation for our planet to
the fishing industries that provide people’s
livelihoods, and food.
And scientists predict that the global population
of synechococcus will go up around 14% by
the end of this century.
Does that mean picocyanobacteria will win?
Who knows.
There are other organisms, and not to mention
entire ecosystems that surround the picocyanobacteria
and that shape their success.
And besides, what does it mean to win,
in a world where the demands of survival are
always in flux?
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And remember, if you’d like to learn
about picocyanobacteria and their chitin
raft adventures, you can head over to youtube.com/eons
to see their episode about it!
The folks on the screen right now, they are
our Patreon patrons.
They’re a bunch of people who individually
could not make this show happen, but when
they all work together, like maybe a bunch
of bacteria in the ocean doing 25% of the
world's photosynthesis, they can make really
amazing and big things happen, like the existence
of this entire channel and its entire multi-year
history.
Thank you so much to all of them.
If you would like to become a Patreon patron,
you can go to Patreon.com/JourneytoMicro.
If you want to see more from our Master of
Microscopes, James Weiss, you can check out
Jam and Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there's
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.